what's up everyone we are currently live
on the streets
we are polling people about their
thoughts on humanity we're gonna see
what they think this is quite the
interesting eclectic array of techies as
well as people that are houseless it's
quite interesting so we'll see who wants
to come on the send shat hey brother
you want to come shot on the set all
right no worries all right we just got
us a simple no you want to chat on the
set brother
no I good you know why don't you tell
our viewers a little bit about that Ali
back oh you can't hear me okay yeah I
see some people coming let's see maybe I
can stop this car and get this driver to
talk to me
hold on yeah your brother want to come
onto the set and talk for a little bit
nice that was a fast turn nice great
what's your name brother Malik had a
great Malakai the great interesting come
we come a center shot for me like a
little more this way thank you we're
doing a show on the thoughts on humanity
we would love to hear what you think
politically stupid and unpack that a
little more for us why we'd like to do
things that you know you know the the
real definition of pain is you know
knowing what is hurting you but you do
it anyways and you just keep on doing it
it's entertaining really you know III
find the ignorance in this video
entertaining but that's just me what are
we doing that we know is causing us pain
but that we keep doing well it's a
really long list give me like the top
worse things that we're doing
war obviously you know anyway any
freedoms we might have can you let's
stay on war for just a second quick how
does that make you feel well I don't
really feel anything I'm an American we
don't have war here no no one's dropping
bombs on us no one's invading our land
we don't the Americans don't understand
what war is because it's on foreign soil
all the time well just because it's
never really come here the the only
Americans that ever you know had any
experience of war were on the Aleutian
Islands during World War two
the only time we ever lost land to a
foreign power Japanese so so the United
States since 1776 has just been gaining
land and never losing land right do you
mind if I smoke please smoke please and
you're welcome to swear you're welcome
to do whatever you want
welcome do whatever you want okay so you
say that this this pain that we have the
pain is that we know what we're doing
wrong but we're not making any changes
about it correct yeah and one of the
main things is war and so what would
humanity at large you know I mean maybe
I don't know if you're referring to the
the question is worth like a society in
general like us thank you I appreciate
that yeah yeah yeah it's society at
large yeah what would like thoughts on
society this has been good so far you've
been you know you've hammered out one of
the big ones can I give you the the
argument that people give is that if the
United States was to sit back and not
have a massive military budget that the
United States would lose because other
people would come and conquer lose what
the United States would have Wars on its
soil
oh yeah that's a bunch of [ __ ] you
think that if the United States had a
like a 10 billion dollar military budget
instead of 600 billion you think that
we would be able to protect ourselves on
this land you think people wouldn't come
invade us well yeah I mean what's really
defending us you know I I happen to
enjoy studying this type of thing I was
protecting us our our the Atlantic the
Pacific and Mexico and Canada yeah yeah
that's huge oh yeah there's some pretty
big walls right there you know yeah it's
a good insight if we didn't have those
if we were like right next to you know
17 other landlocked country yeah exactly
we'd be warned we'd actually spent even
more on our military budget than we do
currently you know you know trust me the
government you know people believe in
like conspiracy theories like the
government has all their [ __ ] together
and stuff they don't they're idiots just
like we are you know they don't know
what they're doing
you know so they throw a bunch of money
at war and really it's just unnecessary
they know what they're doing you know I
wish the I wish the Illuminati existed
and I wish [ __ ] Freemasons were
running [ __ ] now you know it's somewhere
there was like some Grand Council
Council of 13 people like running the
world things would be going pretty well
but there's obviously not you know and
so what we was so now what is to say
that the 13 people running the world the
council running the world the New World
Order how do we guarantee that these are
benevolent Souls well if you read the
Charter for the Illuminati and what the
New World Order is it's actually a quite
positive thing it's it's not really this
doomsday type thing I mean they want a
worldwide currency they want you know
war to stop because it increases trade
you know I mean yeah I mean it's it's
only good things and you know if you
really want war to stop what you do is
you increase trade that's how it's
always been done you know war decreases
as trade increases yes you know when you
go to history classes they often focus
on wars and battles and dates of battles
and stuff but really if you flip it
around and focus on when trade treaties
were signed and new trade routes were
developed that's that's really the
turning points for civilizations because
uh so then this one belt that's
happening right now in China when Bowen
Road
mmm-hmm have you heard of that no
China's making a massive connection
across Asia to Europe and Africa and
Java so that it can more easily trade
resources exactly and so then so then
that the general principle then is that
then there will be less war is that true
well yeah because war is fought over
resources you know it's not fun over
money you know it's not over resources
resources you know turn into money
but yeah I mean once we once we freely
trade resources you know it's okay it's
like when you know there's a bunch of
five-year-olds sitting at a table and
instead of the the big kid hogging all
the toys they all start they'll all
learn how to share suddenly they stop
fighting you know I mean you don't look
into your neighbours bowl you know food
to see if he has more than you you look
in to see if he has enough you know that
way everybody's you know copacetic I
recommend you watch them a great YouTube
channel I can't John Green and I believe
he wrote them the The Fault in Our Stars
he also does a history show going
through the entire world's history and
he's a big believer in in in what I'm
talking about and I'm really I'm just
regurgitating what he said you know can
I can I just unpack this a little bit
more the the idea that if I look at
something and I'm able to share with
fellow people then that is transcending
our animalistic instincts yeah exactly
and it's also encouraging the flea free
flow of science you know
you know the exchange of ideas the trade
also reduces racism you know really a
lot of positive things if you look at
almost every city that is near a
coastline and has a lot of trading
airport they're often much less racist
you know than most other cities you know
as like you know Texas for example you
know or someplace like that
okay thanks dude yeah I'm really
sarcastic dry sense of humor well it's
it's it's good stuff so all right come
at us again with this so if you are near
water it decreases war because you're
not in that landlocked next to another
nation but it also increases your
ability to trade because you're on water
yeah I mean I don't want to say just
that one incidence will decrease war
because it's really up to a nation-state
as a whole right you know but that city
is almost certainly going to be more
liberal and not want to be involved in a
war you know but I mean don't take my
word for it you know you didn't even
research it do you think there's
something about the way that countries
like Switzerland behave that is
intriguing no to me what's intriguing is
how we behave how we the United States
behave yeah and another country to me
that that's out of the norm that's weird
yeah yeah but but but the peace though
they have a lot of money yeah you know
and they got a lot of money through
trade you know so once again you know
they'd rather trade than fight a war you
know what are these other sort of pain
points war was the biggest pain point
that you first started with what's the
next yeah it's the easiest one is there
something else about war before you go
on to the next one if we all refused to
fight there wouldn't be worse you know
and I guarantee you you know Trump isn't
gonna go fight George Bush isn't gonna
fight they ain't gonna send their kids
to go fight
you know they don't have enough jails to
hold all of us you know it it as simple
as ending war on a worldwide scale as
simply as as simple as just saying no
I'm not gonna fight you know and to me
that's kind of the easy way out and then
if you say that you're not going to
fight what's stopping somebody else from
saying that well I want your land and
your resources well I mean that's that's
what we have the I mean you're confusing
our military force you know that defies
foreign powers with with domestic you
know the police are there to make sure
no one takes our land but let's not
forget that the police are the biggest
gang in the United States they they are
the gang that charges protection money
and if you don't pay their protection
wonder they won't take your land you
know I mean so it's kind of you [ __ ]
it okay but there's still this there was
still this point that it there both
sides have to agree to not steal from
each other
oh saying between nations yeah because
it's it's more profitable to have peace
every time you know I mean that that's
always more profitable and you know
realistically speaking uh there's enough
food and resources for everybody there
really is you know I mean if everyone
shared a little bit everyone would have
enough you know they I mean look at the
background here you got all these dope
fiends [ __ ] hog on all their [ __ ]
dope if they all shared there'd be
plenty no one would be dope sick you
know many of the viewers might not get
this oh there's also a you know like a
$4,000 a month one-bedroom condo right
next to us at the same time yeah yeah
the gentrification is pretty extreme
here that there there's also not there
they don't have any interest in sharing
either that's the that's kind of the
lesson so so how would the world ideally
look then before you're come a little
more towards me in the shot so like what
would the what would the world look like
then in an ideal scenario where we are
sharing well first of all every man in
the world would be gay except for me and
I'd get all the women but it would be
like a socialist type of environment you
know where we you know we be sharing and
the government would
take care of the necessities and then
corporations and businesses would it
would take care of luxuries you know
that way you know you can always get
what you need you know but if you want
something else you might have to work
for it you know do you have a that seems
like one of the fundamental principles
of maximizing human potential is giving
people at least the basic food water
shelter education internet electricity
exactly exactly
unnecessary no absolutely well we get
the we need it for information
technology all right so porn how about a
next thing on the list after war what is
this other thing that's causing us lots
of pain that we just keep doing and
ignore lack of perspective you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna search to the side for
my left arm now are you getting tired
the microphone is heavy you're ordering
me around a lot I feel I feel good okay
I'm just making sure you're good because
I like lack of perspective you know I
think perspective is a very underrated
thing you know perspective is not only
knowledge but it is also understanding
it is empathy it is you know looking at
a problem in knowing you know a hundred
different ways of solving it instead of
one you know and it's also understanding
the next person you know and what it's
like to be in their shoes you know which
it's hard to hate someone if you
understand why they're acting the way
they act the why is extremely important
and if you understand why you're much
less likely to hate them you know people
kill spiders because they don't
understand them if they have the
perspective of understanding the spider
they'd probably be okay with it you know
you know yeah yes so you bring up a
couple points their perspective so it's
illness as though if our perspective
gets augmented to new dimensions of
thinking two dimensions of maybe
thinking that rather than seeing one way
to solve a problem we see a hundred ways
that instead of seeing a binary stance
on a political or economic issue we see
a multivariate stance has lots of
variables yeah it's pretty sad
especially with our government you know
one knew we had liberals and
conservatives and everyone's fighting
for one side of the other and and I
swear to god it's amazing that people
don't simply think themselves well maybe
the answer lies somewhere in the middle
[Music]
yeah
extremes typically don't work you know
extremes are war you know or yeah it's
it's said you know don't be a
conservative don't be a liberal you know
rethink err yeah exactly be you you know
and and just and don't be a dick that's
rule number one in life don't be a dick
amen to that
I know yeah yeah I like it is there
another thought on humanity that comes
through and that you'd like to share on
the way out so I recently moved to San
Francisco about a year year and a half
ago welcome thank you and I have never
experienced the drug use like we have
here you know I didn't realize that
drugs were as much of a problem as they
are you know I grew up in Napa Valley in
a really small town you know pretty
privileged and rich and all that you
know we didn't really have homeless
people we didn't have drug addicts you
know hanging on the street you know drug
addiction breeds crime unfortunately
because they need to get their fix and
it's not like they can go you know get
it for free somewhere you know like it
isn't Denmark for example you know I
think that drug addiction is pause there
for a second just because is that
actually a good solution to the problem
is to have it free somewhere and then
have maybe rehabilitation to get away
from I don't I don't like that phrase a
good solution you know a it's a better
solution steal and be violent yeah I
mean let's just go for better right now
we don't need to go for a good or
perfect okay yeah anything
I pretty going
yeah yeah it sure that's true it's true
yeah he's just saying that um that there
is a yeah absolutely I mean society has
always had drugs human civilization for
as long as we've been around I hate to
think I mean where would we be if we
didn't have drugs you know who knows I
am a drug user so you know I obviously
think there are many benefits to it you
know I'm not saying that that drugs are
bad but drug addiction and you know what
we have going on that's what I feel
that's what I'm saying
drugs are fine drugs expand awareness
drug addiction sucks yeah it really does
suck and you know I will tell you as
being a heroin addict myself it's not
it's not really a fun thing at all I
don't think there's any heroin anything
that likes being a heroin at it you know
it just kind of it's a pitfall you fall
into and you can't climb out of it you
know it's a bummer it really is but so
yeah what is that what does that feel
like though - you said it's a pitfall
that you enter in and you can't get out
of what's what is it why is it feel that
way well because you're it pitfall is oh
let me explain pitfall was the type of
trap that humans built to catch animals
we put leaves and sticks on top of it so
the animal does not see it it looks like
normal ground you're just walking and
then all of a sudden you fell into it
and you weren't ready for you weren't
prepared for it there was no way to
avoid it and suddenly you're in there
but you can't get out that's kind of
like drug addiction you know at uh you
know you don't think you're addicted
until suddenly you are you know I myself
you know was a private contractor that's
a non-military personnel in Afghanistan
and I got shot walls over there doctors
gave me oxycontin and I'd never really
done opiates before and all of a sudden
you know before I knew what was going on
I was addicted I called my doctor one
day and said hey I've got a the worst
flu ever had in my life
and I don't have a temperature is really
weird and he said oh you're withdrawing
you know that that's you know from
cutting
off the opiates and I said well like I'm
really sick man like this is this is
shitty it's some of the worst pain I've
ever felt in my life so yeah I went out
and got more opiates you know and a lot
of people will sit there and say to
themselves well you just need to man up
and you need to just go through it I'll
tell you there's better ways to relieve
pain that we have yet to figure out we
have some people that work in biotech
that are figuring out how to target the
specific nerves that are causing the
pain and yeah but the point is of
numbing the whole body yeah but the
point of the addiction once you once
you've you know once you're in that
situation you know it's it's just it's
hard to get out of it and it's it's a
it's a lack of perspective to say that
well you just simply need to stop doing
opiates because especially here being
homeless on the street it's impossible
to go through withdrawal while you're
homeless on the street you are so sick
you can't go to the grocery store you
can't you can't get yourself food you
can't get yourself water you can't walk
you know you need to use the bathroom
every five minutes withdrawing while
you're homeless is not an option so you
know they they have to go out and you
know as I say here in the city hit licks
and commit crimes to get money and what
does hit licks commit crimes
you know I'm ignorant is going out to
commit a crime and specifically that
makes money you know it's not for the
fun of it it's not you know for revenge
or anything like that it is solely to
make money and hadn't heard that term
hit licks yeah yeah you hit a lake I
don't know why they call it that you
know like I said I'm new under to the
street - it's been a year and I'm yeah
you know I am I am from the meadow I'm
not from the ghetto you know but I'm
learning quite quickly what what
happened to go from meadow to ghetto I
explained previously I went to
Afghanistan and got shot and the doctors
gave me oxycontin and I became addicted
it was like that just like that this
that seems like you you you make it you
summarize it in a sentence and you make
it seem as though that that is that
really just that one that one sentence
is can boom
do that to someone yeah absolutely
I mean I went from you know I was 28
years old and I I made you know sixty
thousand dollars a year I had in my own
house I had a brand-new car totally paid
off ahead a girlfriend I've been going
out with for seven years I wanted to
marry a you know two cats I had you know
I had [ __ ] everything and you know I
lost it all within two years and was
almost you know it does happen that
quick and it's it's impossible to stop
on your own you cannot stop by yourself
is it you cannot you know they I don't
care how strong your willpower is if I
took all the dopamine out of your brain
you'd lay on the ground and just right
in pain you know we evolved to have
dopamine in our brains because life
existence is painful within itself you
know that's why we have dopamine you
know you are currently high right now
even without drugs you know you have
dopamine going through your body we have
that to numb the pain of being alive you
know if you didn't have it the wind
hitting you right now it hurt you know
it would everything would just hurt and
that's how it is when you're withdrawing
everything everything like hurts really
bad we're just ticking closer and closer
to good to death yeah on our way out
yeah and we evolved to you know make it
less painful you know so we can function
make it less painful to function so now
you know yes because this is so new and
I don't think you know if messages like
this can get out to more people for
people to actually empathize and care
and gain more perspective gain more
perspective like you were saying earlier
you know I think that could be
tremendously helpful at to work together
like we were initially talking about
what now now so it seems as though there
was a moment
kind of like the logical person in he's
trying to like maybe pinpoint the you
know you had a home girlfriend and
things that you've really enjoyed about
life and then there was a period of time
where you went to hello there was a god
bless San Francisco for having so
beautiful woman here they won't really
talk to me but there they're just saying
it's true it's true yeah okay and then
then there's a call to to war for you
you decide to I was a private contractor
who's not in the military you know I
decided to go because I wanted money
I wanted $150,000 check tax-free that's
what I went for
and then were shot in Afghanistan in
Afghanistan yeah Sean Afghanistan in the
back
yeah bullet ricocheted off a wallet and
hit me in the back right right below
mine jewelry right there shoulder blade
yeah and and then you did you lose some
like some ability bomb and you know it
it and then temporarily in the sense of
having a hole in your back it's kind of
you know it hurts and you can't really
do stuff quite as well as you used to so
I as I recovered for six months you know
doing nothing and taking those
oxycottons as opiates every day you know
and you know being prescribed them by
the doctors doing what I was supposed to
do you know I didn't realize I was
slipping into addiction you know you
don't realize it because you've got all
the dope unita
any opiate addict can be a function in
the opie addict if they have an
unlimited supply you know yeah you know
I could go to I could still make $60,000
a year and be successful if you just
gave me a lifetime supply of heroin you
know I'd be fine but yeah that's when
they cut you off that's when you realize
so like I said it's a pitfall it sneaks
up on you you know you don't realize
it's happened until it's already over
and done with and then all of a sudden
you're there and then it's a it's a so
there's pain and then the pain is it's
dulled by painkillers and then the
painkillers before you know it become
addictive and you don't even realize it
but you're depending depending and
depending and then eventually even
though the pains not there you're still
taking painkillers well yeah because it
doesn't it doesn't take away the pain
forever it just it makes it uh
we're the CIA is here and they're
watching crackheads and tweakers yeah
you know how paranoid they are about the
CIA knowledge and tweeters you know it's
like this this we don't even realize
that six weeks later or six months later
we don't even have pain anymore but
we're still addicted to painkillers the
pain just comes back ten times worse you
know the pain oh it comes back ten times
yeah I mean when you stop taking it yeah
I mean any pain that you were delaying
is worse I mean it's and that's because
we've trained our body to become numb -
yeah yeah it's like lying to your
girlfriend you know I mean it's gonna
it's gonna delay pain now what it's
gonna come back even worse later don't
lie to your girlfriend guys just just
just fess up it's all good you know
right off like a band-aid you know cuz
if you lie to her Chandi yeah she's
gonna she's gonna come back at you and
it's gonna be even worse just get it
over with
you know the same thing with opiates
yeah it's just going to come back so
then so then this this this this period
of time when when it you kind of came to
this realization that [ __ ] I am addicted
and then when you came back you decided
to not go to your home you wanted to
because he wanted to know I tried to go
to rehab I talked to my family for help
I did the whole [ __ ] thing I did
everything I could possibly think of to
try to you know just and I had every
resource available you know and what
family was there 100% my friends and
family everybody you know rehab but you
know it's just a and once you get past
it withdrawal the pain part right you
are depressed for a year or two
afterwards and you cannot it's
impossible to enjoy anything you know my
girlfriend would be like what do you
want for dinner I don't care or do you
want watch a movie I don't care do you
want to have sex I don't care you know
like you literally just don't give a
[ __ ] you know you're just depressed and
you don't nothing makes you happy you
don't there's no genuine smile for a
year or two and that's a long time to
you know not give a [ __ ] about anything
and to be depressed you know eventually
you know it's it's like working 24/7 and
ever getting time off you know
eventually you need a vacation and so
you're like well I'm just gonna you
don't go get high once you know because
I need the sanity of feeling okay you
know and I quit for you know three four
months and you know and then you do it
once and that's it one is never enough
and a thousand is too many so so then it
it uh he's got to get a little stretch
in okay so then the you just you know
this is its insightful you know and it's
uh let's switch again I'll be downwind
yeah yeah yeah so you're nonsmoker I
take it
damn wait come low close you know yeah
that's good perfect what's up
man like he just you know literally you
know literally speechless
you know I mean it's you know just my
story's a little different from you know
other people's but it's all generally
the same you know and and in the end
it's all my fault you know I you know
there really is no excuse you know I
mean I've had many opportunities to stop
and I just I just can't you know yeah
and it sucks being homeless
you know you yeah you used to it though
I happen to be quite good at it you know
you know cuz you see some of the kids
over there I mean they look like [ __ ]
you know yeah you're you've you've maybe
figured out how to like you got a
[ __ ] watch on you know yeah I'm
wearing expensive clothes and they're
clean and you know and and all that what
are you doing how are you doing this in
if I told you I'd have to kill you you
know I mean ergo I'm doing things that I
really shouldn't be doing you know but I
the difference is is that you know I I
happen to be a really intelligent person
and I'm not saying these these other
people are not smart everyone is smart
in their own way absolutely you know but
my type of intelligence it just happens
to fit really well with with being
homeless you know I know how to speak to
people you know my good I'm good at
selling anything you know selling
yourself or whatever or selling the
persona of being something else if you
go into a store to steal something you
are selling the fact that you're not
homeless you know and that you're there
for a legitimate reason and when I walk
into a store I look like a regular
person you know so they don't suspect me
you know they suspect the homeless guy
walking in to buy some ice cream and
watch him the whole time as he makes a
legitimate purpose and I rob them blind
you know that type of thing you know and
just uh you know and I'm you know I'm
willing to work you know I went to
college and you know I got through that
and you know it requires effort just
like being homeless you just got to put
the effort into it yeah yes Ron
just make sure you get him to agree my
name is so-and-so and I agreed um so
yeah my email to would like to stay in
touch as well my real name is Sean
dangle just say that smart man and we
appreciate you coming in and not sharing
your time thank you yeah yeah we really
appreciate it Sean thank you it's all
good man
yeah I guess if you just want to say
that you know that you know any any last
thoughts about drugs are bad okay okay
thanks Sean Alan do you want to you want
to link up on email or anything yeah
yeah what is it it's a shot
you know nothing but time on my hands as
you know homelessness tends to do you
know something that we care a lot about
is highlighting people's lives and a lot
of people that we highlight are building
some sort of future and technology or in
science or and in or in business it's
it's it's over there it's it's in its in
its up probably upstairs on that yeah I
know I know yeah that's fine we'll find
another person right now
yeah real doping over here that's pretty
intense that's pretty intense
I've got a few morals and I you know I
try yeah sad you know I mean look at
that this is a [ __ ] sad you know this
is it to me it's like dirty and grimy
and [ __ ] it's the most depressing
thing in the world I walked down this
alley to look for two friends I wish I
wouldn't be hanging out here you know I
wish we had the robocam to get a shot of
this it would be less conspicuous as
well one thing that you like everything
the whole story that you told and then
where it leads us to back to the
beginning for me it makes it feel like
the partly war has caused people
physical ailments and then that has cost
some addiction to drugs I will say a lot
of military personnel struggle with this
problem more so than the average person
you know I mean because they give out
opiates like candy there and as much as
I disagree with war and and everything
that we did in Afghanistan it wasn't the
right thing to do you know we still need
to support people that were damaged by
it and we really should be helping them
you know because they don't deserve to
lose everything through drug addiction
you know even if you don't lose your
house and all that you still lose
yourself you know it sucks when you
can't have sex with your girlfriend or
I'd like to bring up the
the the the the Afghanistan opium poppy
trade right now told you to go [ __ ] off
I need to go make some money
so I get more dope you know because
that's what's important is I will not be
I want I'm not gonna be sick [ __ ] all
that wow I can't believe that what is
just it's blowing my mind the connection
back to the beginning about how the
taking care of veterans taking care of
kids and and building a bright future
and and really really respecting if
opiates are given like candy of course
there's gonna be a massive addiction and
then what do we do about what we have
now it's a waste of human intelligence
you know there are a lot of smart people
out here I'm not the only smart guy and
the other artists out here you know
there's there's people who can really
contribute to society but they're unable
to do so is a waste and I actually I
actually wanted to tell you that that we
have talked to people out here and
they've been philosophers or writers or
artists musicians and it's just been so
interesting talking to people out here
really taking time to talk to them
because we're regular people you know
and in many ways you're out of the
matrix and in sometimes some of them are
in the matrix but some people in normal
life are also in the matrix a lot of
them are and if I if I do have one thing
to say um you know when you're walking
down the street and you're a rich white
person right and you see some homeless
people the the look of pity disgust and
fear you know like you're afraid of us
really is just the most insulting thing
in the world
you know we you know they look at us
like animals or we're not we're not
gonna hurt you we're not gonna Rob you
you know you know you you know you don't
have to treat us like pariahs you know I
hate it when I walk by and I say hi as I
pass by someone and they just don't even
say anything like it don't exist you
know it's it's not polite and it's it's
it's [ __ ] up you know it only and only
perpetuates the drug addiction because
it makes you feel like garbage you know
it sucks the way we are treated bike
there the general population especially
rich people because there's that gap and
they're so far above and they feel like
they're they're different you know yeah
yeah it sucks it's just another human
it's just two humans it's not yeah it is
you know but
yeah
yeah what are you guys doing what are
you doing we're we're doing two or three
nights ago so Maya don't have my phone
right now I'm sure I'll acquire one
again but don't expect an email back
with it you know like right away yeah
that's pretty crazy that robbed at
gunpoint these are [ __ ] real things
dude yeah this is real [ __ ] [ __ ] and
for that all the time you know on
Christmas Day not last for the Christmas
before that someone took a knife to my
head zoom in on that I mean wow it's
it's part of life on the street yeah
it's brutal sometimes you imagine if you
lost every single possession you have
every single month like everything
except for the clothes on your back
you lose everything once a month and
it's [ __ ] frustrating as [ __ ] you
know you can I've been playing this
[ __ ] role-playing game over and over
my [ __ ] phone and each time I lose my
phone I got started over and it's really
frustrating me that's the stuff that
pisses me off like I like video games
you know I want to finish that
role-playing game but I can't because
people keep on robbing me it's [ __ ] up
and you just it's it's so usually a
violent act when someone's like you do
you have your backpack and they're just
like have a weapon and they ask you well
yeah either they steal it you know and
you don't notice or or they or they rob
you and you know if you were on the
street and you don't fight back it
doesn't matter if there's a whole army
that you're gonna fight against you need
to fight because if you don't you're
gonna be labeled as a [ __ ] and yeah and
they'll keep on robbing you and yeah you
got a fight you know you've got a fight
you know and I and I [ __ ] hate
fighting and hate it so much you know I
don't like hurting people I don't like
being hurt yeah that's that's but
circles us all the way back again to
what we were saying about war let's not
forget that a violence is the lowest
form of human communication there is the
lowest form you know it's ridiculous
there's no other there's no other lower
form of a way to [ __ ] to get an idea
across
besides I disagree with you and I'm just
going to punch you so that way you can't
disagree with me any longer
don't use your words or anything like
that you know it's just I deserved every
beat and while John okay sorry brother
it's fantastic this is so great yeah I
you know I try to be upbeat and positive
and joke around and stuff you know
because you know life still isn't that
bad you know I have fun it's okay yeah
everything's okay yeah yeah
god bless Godspeed Alan such a good kid
well that was absolutely crazy and very
unexpected and welcome to the rear I
wasn't expecting a very deep and long
conversation like that and initially
having it start out with war and land
and water and violence and greed and and
then to talk about perspective and
augmenting perspective and seeing things
from you know a hundred different ways
instead of just one way and then his
story about how he had what he wanted in
life and then how so many veterans go
through this I can't believe opiates are
given like candy that seems like the
craziest thing in the world
and then we make our foreign policy
advances on the backs of human mental
health being sacrificed for it and that
doesn't seem right
seems very wrong well that was a very
very insightful and heart-touching
conversation very grateful to be doing
this and have water and food let's see
if other people will talk to us for a
little bit longer it's not can happen
maybe you want to just do that then
please do you want to talk on our show
for a little bit we're talking about
like thoughts on humanity let me get
this car I'm currently doing a show I'm
wondering if you have any thoughts on
humanity that you'd like to share with
us you pull up into my shop quick pull
in the shop well let's see it keep
coming keep coming keep coming keep
coming sauce not perfect perfect do you
have do you have any thoughts on
humanity you would like to share with us
in any way that comes to mind the first
thought about humanity that comes to
mind like what would he think about us
like how we do it I mean I say we're
pretty good like an evolving but you
know how it is nowadays you know with
the president the government you know
it's kind of BS okay it could be better
but you know what could we do as much as
we chatter protest whatever nothing
never nothing ever works I could I ask
the steel you for five minutes for a
quick conversation you guys in a rush
you're in a rush
I appreciate the quick wisdom thanks for
sharing
thank you for stopping Wow that was
interesting
let's see if I can stop another car you
don't talk to us No okay let me see if I
can get this guy hold on
I'm gonna stop by and chat for a bit
yeah we're having it we're just talking
to people about the thoughts on humanity
like what the hell is on their mind like
what's the status of the world we know
yeah you want to want to chat for bids
you sparkup what is that joint yeah yeah
yeah no yeah cigarette yeah somewhere up
in the up in the cap you get like what
do you what do you thoughts on what's
going on in the world today we come into
the shot a little days ago yeah well
from Big Island oh yeah you were from
Big Island I grew up there I grew up
here I grew up
yeah I've been there since I was a
little munchkin but yeah everything
looks good I like the architecture
people are cool I think if people
believe in themselves a little more or a
lot more each of us me too you know all
of us everyday and you know that'll
spread it believing in each other
oh so whatever we make it you know a
little bit more belief in every single
one of us like you got to look in the
mirror and be like I love myself like I
got to go and like yelling people
whatever it's like let's see the God in
them and from their reach their
individual person we all got that
sparked called
life or soon now why'd you move from Big
Island to San Francisco goodbye mom bye
book the volcano hit my house well
actually all these [ __ ] no was like oh
he's struggling and so she pulled me out
of the tape and Fema camp you know after
the kind o there there we the rescue
rescue camps were said I know yeah those
that had lava literally destroyed their
house
yeah exactly so I'm this here just like
kicking with moms and you know it's cool
I like it
damn so you just came here like three
weeks ago and now you're here and tell
your home or I go back or stay I don't
know I like it was a lot more people so
it's fun more people here but the vibe
is not this Pacific Ocean like chill
even though we're on the Pacific I see
it like I just see rainbows you know so
I don't really see rainbows we're big
island where like everywhere like I'm
blind to the hate like whatever might be
happening in someone's world I pretty
much don't see it you know unless I show
up afterwards and then it's like oh that
happened why did that happen
whatever's happening in the world
meeting like everybody's life is vivid
and complex and difficult to understand
yeah raw emotional beings and spiritual
beings and physical beings so balancing
all that yeah you know people out here
feeling justified like I'd rather sit on
the street and chilled and support a
government who's hurting others but at
the same time there's weights where you
could realize well those people are
probably praying for a rescue you know
I'd rather just you know chill in the
park or Shawn the beach then support a
government that's fighting a war killing
people I mean it is our government
essentially our parents paid into it
with their you know time so it's not the
it's not people that are wrong it's
paperwork that just got to be upgraded
and I mean to fit with the times because
when those papers were written people
were a little you know focused on that
time and age so now we're in this time
and age so just take say hey that was
good you know it's updates to the
software that and updates to history our
story thanks for watching our story
instead of history yeah
all is exactly like you know tribal
community how is all the truth of what
it's been a lot of writers journalists
were just indoor people they never got
out to really know they just got the
urethane road and I know from
experiences I've been written about in
the papers and it's like well that
didn't happen but okay you know so if
that can happen in two or three hours
imagine years you know so yeah ever and
every every it's all good like really
it's just how you wanna force or how we
individually would like to perceive it
right it's a blessing to be born but
it's also we really be born into some
suffering as well now it's more like
mental suffering it's not so physical as
we developed countries it can be
definitely be seen that way for sure yes
it's it's training if you're trained to
believe the year from a lower Society
then you're not gonna really strut
higher right if you're trained to
believe we're all divine royalty you
know that'll be it's like oh I get high
that's divine okay cool then we can keep
inventing and making music and
you don't mean and for the good of the
people it's just intention what's your
name
I'm Alan what's your name good to meet
you man good to meet you hi love good
love ah man it's like a tea party
wee-wees distance drink tea and then
they smoke ganja that's like yo I'm not
gonna leave my mom down cuz or my cousin
or my friend or even a stranger just cuz
they're doing it you know it's like oh
that's not natural well what about cars
didn't okay no so it's all good just
bless it up what are you what are you
kind of like what are your plans while
you're here shoot I got a chance to just
be next to my mom just like supporting
my mom like I'm 40 years old and I was
out there doing my thing and I've got
another house and everything but I'm
like you're getting another house you
got one mom in another moment that's you
know that time space is a lot of
youngsters I see like what would you do
like well if I was younger I'd go back
and live with my mom and help fulfill
some of her dreams since she brought me
into this world take it is like blessing
in it like oh I get the chance
Wow it's just fun in the Sun here with
mom and you get to kind of have that
feeling that many people don't even get
to tap into which is my mom brought me
and I want to help my mom be happy and
it's hard worker she's got her ideas and
from like an ancient realm like we
should I don't know she was born I'm
like ancient she was born like dr. King
was a lot
so it's like ancient Edo and you know
that because this is difference like you
know it's all good
she sees the house she sees it and I
just respect that cuz you have another
maybe like piece of like wisdom or
thought on humanity that you think would
be important to communicate treat
everyone like family care I mean why
something screaming in the street
already they have to make it care so
like I said I could get deeper better
get a little deeper like care okay care
like I met some kids who were and I'm or
do you call that foster homes right they
were taken from their parents my grow
was my mom were cool on long no one
could ever take she she looked at us
like my mom was this big but she wasn't
pushing slammed the door in the
government's face like no this is our
country blank you know they're my kids
but and run along was but for a lot of
people a lot of my good friends or their
lives were deeply are still disrupted by
their experience being adopted or you
know having these government sanctions
that take them away from their parents
and their parents were hardcore drug
addicts but at least they could go to
the fridge and rip a bag of cereal over
their teeth there's something where is
you know not everyone's intentions are
right just because they can do the
paperwork
this idea of care i think is very be
built deep within us but now has become
disconnected from us in some ways so I
wanted gardens seeds like buting seeds
if I don't know this like if if I if
someone tells me I'm a piece of [ __ ]
because of the decisions I make there's
no way to get out of that and I'm going
to continue to
build diamonds and gold out of [ __ ]
because I'm piece of [ __ ] so if we put
each other up on a pedestal I mean it I
mean like reverse crabs in a bucket like
and then we then it's like oh you're
ascended bean that's why you are doing
these you know whatever it is that
people don't agree with in the cities
you know like people people complain all
the homeless people is garbage
everywhere they're pooping ever I don't
see any bathrooms anywhere so it's like
well are you looking for a solution or
you're looking for this negative energy
too you know so that's the caring again
you know Sun shines on everyone so might
as well Sun shines on everyone yeah yeah
so we might as well care I might as well
shine shine on each other Hilary like
brothers and sisters if my mom took nine
grand for me I'm not gonna be like act
like I don't know her you know so why
would I treat a stranger the same that
someone's that male so this has been
doing good thanks man thanks for shine
oh yes down there we get all our good
books back hell yeah oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
Al and I can't believe that guys vote
the Volk a note swallowed up his house
he's here telling us to care about each
other he's like looking around like damn
SF is how the people look at this
architecture it's kind of funny yeah
it's right he's right about care well
I'm cold and I want to head in and I
want to tell you guys that this has been
very insightful thanks for tuning into
it this episode on thoughts of humanity
thoughts on humanity thoughts on
humanity thoughts on and it's good
because we get a little bit of diverse
perspectives you know a little bit of
here a little bit of there you know like
the quick car stopped the car came by we
talked a little bit and then they had to
go know so that was nice as well and you
know join us join us like you know it's
crazy we talked to scientists we talked
to entrepreneurs technologists educators
different world leaders and then we come
out here on the street and we talk to
people on the street
random people that's right some of them
are some of them had crazy life-changing
experiences that have caused them to
live in different ways to see the world
in different ways that it much more
unique in some ways than how we see the
world and that's also valid perspective
that we think is very important to show
on the show and it's very insightful so
thanks for tuning in everyone if you
guys had a good time going show this
with two people how often do you see
content like this you don't see it very
often
with clothes in there Oh hats ask you
know had you need it'll get a little bit
of feminine energy on the show so share
with two people how often do you see
stuff like this go share with two people
have them share with two people let's go
start a little community movement
subscribe comment below with your
thoughts we'd love to hear from you what
do you think about all this and join us
on patreon help us support this help us
get out to more places and do more
videos like this around the place
much love thanks for tuning in and we'll
see you guys on another thoughts on
humanity soon yeah good job Allen good
job
[Music]